hey this is presto Walker this math
problem was asked to primary school
students in China and it's causing huge
debate online as people are arguing
about what the correct answer should be
can you figure it out give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for the solution in
order to solve this problem you have to
pay very careful attention to the
pictures for example the third equation
has a term which involves two whistles
the corresponding term in the very last
line involves only one whistle
furthermore the cat in the third line
has a whistle around its neck and in the
very last line there is no whistle so we
have to take these differences into
account to get the correct value for the
very last line so let's solve each
equation we start out where we have a
pair of shoes plus a pair of shoes plus
another pair of fuse which equals 30 so
we have three pairs of shoes which
equals 30 this means that a single pair
of shoes is equal to 30 divided by 3
which equals 10 we'll use this
information to solve the next equation
we now have a pair of shoes plus two
terms where we have a cat that has
whistle around its neck equaling 20 the
pair of shoes is equal to 10 we then
have two terms of the cat with the
whistle around its neck and this equals
20 so we have two of the terms of the
cat with the whistle around its neck
equal to 10 which means one of these
terms is equal to 10 over 2 which equals
5 we'll now use this to solve the next
equation
we have a cat with the whistle around
its neck plus two whistles plus two
whistles equals 13 the cat with the
whistle is equal to five and then we
have four different whistles which will
group together to be 13 so we have four
whistles is equal to 13 minus 5 which is
8 therefore a single whistle is equal to
8 over 4 which equals 2 so we're almost
done but we have to solve one more
equation and it's not even part of our
original problem we have a cat with the
whistle is equal to a cat without a
whistle plus the whistle so we know the
value of the cat with the whistle is 5
and we know that the whistle is equal to
2 therefore we can solve that the cat
without the whistle is equal to 3 so now
we figure out all the information we
need to evaluate the last line correctly
what is the value of a pair of shoes
plus a cat without the whistle times a
whistle the pair of shoes is 10 the cat
without the whistle is 3 and the whistle
is equal to 2 now in order to get the
correct value we have to use the order
of operations and correctly evaluate 3
times 2 first multiplication takes
precedence over addition so we have 10
plus 3 times 2 which is 10 plus 6 and
that gives us the correct answer of 16
did you figure it out thanks for
watching this video please subscribe to
my channel I make videos on math you can
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
if you like this video you can support
me on patreon or check on my books which
are listed in the video description you
can also catch me on social media either
at pressure locker or at mind your
decision
depending on the site